I am considering spending the required
minimum of six months and one day in
Tennessee to qualify as a Tennessee
State resident and not pay state income
tax same reason Joe Rogan moved to Texas
they don't have state income tax
Tennessee is exactly that way no state
income tax if you're not physically in
Tennessee for that six months and one
days then you're out of luck so being on
tour doesn't count so I would have to
take my schedule and really really
meticulously say okay I can spend four
months of the year on tour then less
than two months of the year in LA and a
full six months and one day minimum in
Tennessee and then I qualify